God uh that's a hard question to answer
I once can't even remember you know
early on when I started writing the
column it was a joke I was going to be
the gay advice columnist who was as rude
to straight people as straight advice
columnist always had been to gay people
and it was just a gag
and straight people really responded to
that kind of contemptuous treatment and
started sending me real letters and
suddenly I had to answer real questions
from real people and I didn't know jack
about particularly women's bodies
because I stopped paying attention once
I realized I wouldn't that was a country
I was never going to visit I didn't need
the bad ecers you know and so yeah I
didn't know how the clit worked and I
gave lousy advice about getting women
off that got me yelled at I think the
worst and perhaps most damaging advice I
ever gave was to Jake shears who I met
when he was 15 years old and he asked me
if he should come out to his parents and
he described you know what was going on
and who they were and what you know what
he thought they might know and after he
told me everything I was like oh they
know they're just waiting for you to
tell them you should tell him just come
out to them they're waiting they're
ready and he came out to them and they
didn't know it was a big disaster and
they tried to pull him out of school and
they were you know really angry and so I
he called me I had a radio show that he
called me and I got him off the air and
got his mother's phone number and called
my mother and gave my mother Jake's
mother's phone number and had my mom
call his mom and yell at her and it
helped but yeah I gave them some really
shitty advice and that is really shitty
advice there's a lot of bad advice for
gay middle schoolers and high schoolers
out there telling them that they should
just come out and not everybody's in a
position where that's the wise were safe
and we have to tell these gay teenagers
to take a cold hard look at who their
families are where they live before they
take that step
most of the bully gay kids are kids who
can't hide and can't pass for straight
and gay adults need to be careful about
telling as I was not at that moment
telling fifteen-year-olds to come out
something like 40% of homeless teenagers
are gay and lesbian teenagers have been
thrown out of the house when they were
outed or came out and unless we're
willing to take as a community financial
responsibility where these kids who get
thrown out we just can't glibly tell
middle schoolers that they have a
responsibility to come out and middle
school make it better for themselves if
really is going to imperil their lives
and their futures to do that you have to
come out from position with strength and
you have some security and now I get
grief because I tell kids who are in
college his parents are paying for
college who would cut them off - wait
wait - the last check clears in your
senior year and then come out that said
you can sometimes gay people will
underestimate their families because
they want to justify they're empowered
us some people don't come out to their
families when they could and their
families would be supportive and the gay
person is just afraid and they inflate
they met they exaggerate their family's
homophobia in a self-serving way as an
excuse never to come out when I meet a
30 year old who's that out to their
family it's all you know it's always at
their families so homophobic and really
what's going on there is that that gay
person is a and a coward and
so they make their families out to be
these monsters that they're not
necessarily and so they don't sit still
they don't ever have to like live with
some integrity and honesty and ethics
and I have no sympathy for those people